so everyone here's uh me talking about
the Octo project
and um
this is going to be a bit of a Hands-On
well not my hands aren't actually not
yours but there's going to be a live
demo because what I want to do is to
show you not only talk about what yocto
is I want to show you how it works and I
want to persuade you that yocto is not
at all scary
like everybody said it is
so
let's see how this goes
let's get back right so these are the
topics
um so I'm going to start off with just a
general chat about yokto and embedded
and why we need it
but the main thing I want to talk about
is how do we use the Octo to do
something useful
and I'm going to build some images and
run them on my laptop using the qemu
emulator
and just to prove that I'm doing
something slightly unusual here I'm
going to be using an arm-based emulator
so we're going to be running arm 32-bit
code
let's talk a little bit though about
embedded and what this is all about
so these are the sorts of Hardware that
we're going to be running Linux on
and in particular embedded Linux
so we have first of all what I call
commodity Hardware
so this is stuff that you buy and you
kind of plug and play
um the most obvious thing here would be
a PC
all PCS are roughly speaking the same
um so their x86 based
um they have fairly powerful processors
but they're quite expensive and quite
power hungry so they're not suitable for
every job
um
we have things like Raspberry Pi
so Raspberry Pi is also a commodity
Hardware you can buy it quite easily
well if you used to actually they're out
of stock at the moment
um but it's pretty much Plug and Play
you plug it in plug some keyboard and
whatever in and you've got a working
system
and you can use Raspberry Pi's for
embedded use
hopefully not the pie itself although I
do know people who do use off-the-shelf
Raspberry Pi's for inverted but they do
a thing called the compute module the CM
stands for compute module that's
essentially an industrial strength
Raspberry Pi
so in these cases you can use standard
distros and it should pretty much work
then we have bespoke Hardware so by
bespoke I mean Custom Design boards and
actually this is the majority of what
embedded really is
so why do we go to the trouble of
Designing our own computer board when
there are computers readily available
and really it becomes if you have large
enough volumes it's actually cheaper to
manufacture your own boards and
customize them to exactly your own
requirements rather than buying off the
shelf boards so to a certain extent it's
a question of volume and economics
uh these things for reasons of course
mostly um are tend to be based on
arm-based systems
um although risk five is a another
architecture that's been around for a
while but it's really catching on over
the last two three years
so I expect us when I do this
presentation in a couple of years time
I'll be putting risk five there up there
alongside arm
and then there's something in the middle
which I call Semi bespoke
so this is sbc's and soms so an SBC is a
single board computer
in other words it's
basically everything you need on a board
and you plug in some peripherals and
Away you go
and in that sense a Raspberry Pi is a
single board computer
and there's also soms system on module
so the system on module you have a
little module which contains the
processor and all the all the expensive
parts and then it has a connector at the
bottom and you plug it into a baseboard
and that baseboard then has your Custom
Electronics
and the advantage here is that the Som
that has the expensive
multi-layer board so 10 layers 14 layers
or whatever they're quite expensive and
quite tricky to manufacture
and then the baseboard has the cheaper
Electronics running at lower frequencies
and doing the custom stuff you need so
it's a halfway house it's great again
for fairly low volume systems where you
don't have the in-house resource to do a
CPU design
so
um yeah
so PCS will be great
um but not really flexible enough to
expand save two power hungry for the
majority of applications
so we end up using arm socs SOC as a
system on chip so essentially that's a
CPU and lots of peripherals integrated
onto the same package
so the peripherals will include
typically a GPU USB controllers Ram
controllers flash controllers I squared
C loads and loads of different
interfaces just ready to go
so you want to run Linux on this thing
obviously
um
so what are you going to do if it's a
commodity system then probably
somebody's already implemented something
like Debian to run on their or Ubuntu or
something
so it's quite common with commodity
Hardware like x86 and Raspberry Pi to
use just a standard distro
but if you're not using that then you've
got to make your own distro somehow
so you could actually sit down and Port
Debbie into your Hardware
turns out there's a non-trivial exercise
that most people wouldn't want to do
so instead we have these
um
systems like yocto which will allow us
to generate a distro to our own
requirements
which brings me on to the Octo project
so yokto project
so this is basically a set of tools that
will allow you to generate a Linux
distro
so if you go look at the Octo website
that it says somewhere on the front page
yocto is not a distro but yocto allows
you to create your own distro
so with the Octo you feed it some rules
and specifications of what you want to
build
and then you set it building
and then you come back three or four
hours later hopefully it's done what you
had to do and you now have some images
which you can just flash into your
system or put into an SD card and boot
your your target device from
um
so yorktail is used in many many things
you use the Octo every day even though
you don't realize it
so just as an example these actually are
also open source projects which in turn
are based on yocto
I put this up there up here because well
partly because there's nice logos I
wanted to use
um so web OS
webos is used for lots of things in
particular it's used by LG for their
Smart TVs so if you have an LG TV it's
running yocto
Automotive grade Linux
that also is based on the Octo it's used
in the head units of vehicles especially
the Japanese manufacturers particularly
like this so if you have a Toyota you
are running yocto in Your Entertainment
System
and the one you can't see because of the
lighting is called oniro
so Nero is a fairly new eclipse-based
project
um and it's it's only towards this iot
Internet of Things idea
and it has integration with Zephyr which
somebody was speaking about yesterday
and also with the Octo project the yocto
part of it typically is used as a
Gateway and the Zephyr part is typically
used for the for the remote sensors
and oh just back to that
um yeah so how many devices are running
yocto in the world today well the answer
is nobody knows because nobody actually
counts
um but a rough estimate I would say 100
million plus
um it's you know there are more things
running yocto uh than
um
okay I wish I said that now I was trying
to think of an analogy that's roughly a
hundred thousand but I can't think of
one imagine something
a little history so actually knowing a
little of the history does help in this
case because it helps explain some of
the terminology which the names of
things that kind of got mangled a little
bit over the last few decades
so yokto started off actually as a
project called open embedded 2003.
now for those of you who remember 2003
that is the time at which it became
possible to run Linux on mobile devices
so 2003 we had the Compaq ipac we had
the sharp zorus and we had the Sim pad
by whoever made the Sim pad I don't
remember
so these are all handheld devices arm
processors obviously arm socs
um I think they are typically four or
eight megabytes of RAM and a few
megabytes of flash memory which at that
time was ample to run Linux
so there's a whole bunch of people
hacking around with their stuff and
producing Linux distros to run on these
and they came together 2003 pulled all
the resources and they produced open
embedded
now it turns out many of the problems
that they had solved were also relevant
to more traditional embedded devices so
not just mobile but just anything that
has constrained resources
next interesting thing is
um around about the same time there was
a British company called opened hand
and they had a contract amongst others
with Nokia to help with the software for
the Nokia
n770 webpad which if you've ever had one
of these things it's a really nice
little devices and it's an iPad before
iPads existed
the guy who was working on that is a guy
called Richard Purdy
and um one of the things he did is he
created a fork of open embedded and he
started doing QA and kind of managing it
a little bit because opening Betty was
kind of chaotic at that time
so he produced a stable version of open
embedded and he called it Pocky Linux
and a lot of people actually myself
included switched to using poki Linux
because it was guaranteed to work from
day to day whereas Oakland Betty
typically didn't
um somewhere along the line opened hand
got bought out by Intel
but for some of those technology they
they had but Intel weren't really
interested in poki Linux
so 2010 they came together with Linux
foundation and they spun out what used
to be called Pocky Linux and they called
it yocto project
so the key thing to remember here we
have three different names basically for
the same thing we have open embedded we
have we have Pocky and we have the Octo
and those names get rather confused
because even the people who work in
those areas
use them somewhat interchangeably
I mean it's Pocky Pocky is a
very tasty a breadstick and chocolate
based snack popular in Japan and other
places and Richard tells me that it is
definitely pronounced Pocky not Pokey a
lot of people pronounce it Pokey doesn't
really matter but the official
pronouncement is Pocky
so now we have
the Octo project
it has a stable release cycle now it
releases twice per year on a six month
cycle in roughly speaking uh April and
October although sometimes there are
maybe a month late
so these are the most recent versions
there are more but they wouldn't fit on
the slide these are the most recent
versions now over here on the right hand
side you can see the status
so each version is maintained by the
Developers for 12 months
and then it's end of life so these are
all marked EOL
but every now and again they choose a
version that will have long-term support
LTS
and they are supported for 24 months
still not a huge length of time but hey
is an improvement
okay so so that's a little bit of the
background on yocto and white exists and
a little bit about how it's managed
so let's start off then by getting a
copy of yocto and doing something with
it
so yokto you can get um by doing a git
clone as shown here there are also tar
balls you can download but it's simpler
to use a git Repository
and with a minus B option you specify
the version notice the versions are
given using code names such as kirkstone
not the version numbers I find this kind
of annoying because it means I've got to
remember both the version numbers and
the code names and remember which one is
which
and yeah so I do
I'll get clone minus B Kirk Stone which
is the latest version
and I get about 250 megabytes uh in the
git Repository
of which 55 megabytes is actual code and
the rest is just the git history
so yomto is actually quite small
that's because it doesn't contain any
source code it just contains the
metadata the rules on how to build
source code
you have to do a little bit of mucking
around to get the environment set up so
you have to initialize your shell by
sourcing this script
in order to set up various variables and
other things that are needed by the Octo
build system
so you begin by doing source
uh OE init build end
and optionally where it says build there
you can give the name of a directory
where you want to create your project
if you don't do anything it defaults to
build
and then it will create a directory by
default called build
it will CD into that directory so that's
now your current directory
and it will create
um a couple of configuration files which
you can edit to set up exactly what you
want
one thing that people often forget is
you have to do this every time you come
to yocto with a new shell
uh so yeah you always need to Source
um OE net build and the environment for
every new shell
and what do you get
um so this is the kind of layout you're
going to end up with so here is the top
level so if you just do the get clone
without giving any directory name it's
going to end up being called Pro key
again you can see the conversion the
confusion here really should be called
yocto but it's called Pocky
um
then there's the build directory we just
created these are the configuration
files which I'm going to look at in a
moment or two
and then here we have uh in this case
three directories called meta something
so these are meta layers
um and I'll describe what the layers are
about in a few slides of time
so in your conf directory you have
bblayers.com for local.conf
so bblayers.com is just a list of all of
those meta layers
and you'll all start off with the three
we just looked at
and then local.com is additional
configuration so here we're going to set
the machine and the distro and various
other things
um here's a diagram which is meant to
show how this all links together
so here's maybe layers.com file that is
literally just a list of directories
which contain uh recipes
So Meta and metapocky are examples of
that
and then Within These meta layers we
just have
um a
a Shoal of BB files
so BB stands for bitbag which is the
build tool and these are bit bait
recipes
so each one of those BB files is going
to create some kind of buildable
artifact in this case here it's going to
build g-lib C the C library for me
so BB layers is pointing to my uh my
layers and then local.conf that has that
is the local configuration which
includes things like the machine and the
distro that I want to base my my build
on
so this brings us then to
three Central Concepts to yocto
the distro the machine and the image
and these are kind of three variables
you can change them independently with
each other which is quite neat
so let's just go through them so the
distro is how do I want to put my system
together
so the distro has is a configuration
which sets some policy decisions so
it'll be things like do I want to use
the latest version of every library or
do I want to be more conservative and
used all the more tested versions
um
which init manager do you want to use do
I want to use system D or system five
init or some other init diben
yeah policy decisions of that sort which
then apply to everything you build
the time you don't need to fiddle with
the distro so at least for beginners you
can ignore distro and just leave it as
the default which is called Pocky
then machine
this is a pointer to the board you're
going to build for
so machine is going to be Raspberry Pi
or beaglebone or
any other of the machines that are
supported
so that's the hardware
and then image image is really just a
list of packages that I want to build
so it's the list of all the things I
want installed into my
um into my image and therefore will be
available to me at runtime
so just to quickly clarify that then
distro you said in your local dot conf
with a term like this distro Pocky
um I'm not going to go into the question
mark equals bit
one of the interesting things about
bitbake is it has 10 different ways of
assigning variables this is one of them
I'm really not going to go into that
because
we don't have time
then for machine you select the machine
you want to build for
so machine beagle bone yocto in this
case
this actually is referring to a file so
that is actually referring to a
configuration file be called beaglebone
yocto which in this case would be in
this meta layer
and actually the same with as I meant to
say this with um uh with distro the name
of the distro is just actually a
configuration file so somewhere in a
distro directory there is a pocky.conf
and then we come to the tool that does
the building which is called bitbake
um
so bitbake processes recipes and also
the the contents of these configuration
files
it will it will build a dependency tree
and then it will uh schedule those jobs
in the fastest sequence possible to get
the the work done
now the images
uh they are specified by recipes not by
a configuration in your local.conf
so there are recipes called things like
core Dash image Dash something so for
example call Image minimal is the
minimum thing you need to boot up and
get a command shell
um core image base does the same but a
little bit more it has some
functionality including things like
being able to load kernel modules
and then there are more sophisticated
images with more and more functionality
within them typically what you'll do is
you will take one of these that most
closely matches what you want to achieve
and then you'll modify that to add in
the particular packages you need to do
your particular job
so to build an image you just do this
bit core image many more
and
like I say the bills typically take
several hours so you come back later and
you'll find it's uh it's built
everything
and I should say that when it's doing
the build not only is it just combining
those recipes the first thing it does
actually is to build the cross compiler
so we start off with nothing we build
the cross compilers from Source
typically GCC but can also be clang
um then we build any other tools
required for build time and only then
can we start actually compiling code for
the Target machine
oops so demo build an image for qemu arm
this is where your all goes wrong
so bear with me
right so I have here a copy of Pocky
kirkster which I downloaded earlier
and this is more or less as I showed on
the slides
um so we have these various meta
directories and we have over here a I
know we don't have a build directory
because I haven't actually set this up
yet okay so we're starting from a blank
slate so I'm going to do Dot
o e init whatever and I'm going to call
build Q E Nu
okay so that is now
um
put me into the direct into that
directory we have the conf directory
if we look in conf we have BB layers and
local.com and one other random file
which I'm not interested in
now I need to make a couple of changes
to the configuration so I need to edit
Comfort local comps
and I need to add a couple of things in
here and I've got a crib sheet over here
which I'm going to from
I'll explain exactly why I'm doing this
later on I think
oops
so I'm sending a couple of pointers and
then down here I need to select the
machine
so the machine I want is going to be the
first one in this list qemu arm is going
to be a 32-bit Arm System
um I could have chosen arm64 also mips
powerpc x86 and there are other things I
could add in by adding an appropriate
meta layers
okay so if everything's done right I can
now type bit
cool
base
and I'll just hang on a second to see if
it actually starts up
so if anybody here was on my workshop we
did Monday Tuesday where we're doing
this for the Raspberry Pi you'll know
that I got this entirely wrong and the
builds which were meant to take about
five minutes actually took like four
hours
I'm hoping this is going to take more
like five minutes
so you see now it says parsing recipes
so
um it's going through all the recipes
it's got It's building a big long list
of them and working out dependencies and
now it's working out what it needs to do
in order to build the thing I wanted and
see up here it says machine is QE mu arm
uh distribution is Pocky 401
and now you can see it's kind of running
through very very quickly
um all of the tasks it has to build this
yeah
so we'll leave that running for a little
while I'll come back to that in a slide
or two
so what I'm hoping we're going to find
at the end of this is that
um
so this is my build directory which I
call build qemu
and it will have well okay
the stuff it downloads in order to build
stuff ends up in a DirecTV called
downloads there's a thing called the
shared State cache
but the real interesting stuff is in a
directory rather confusingly called temp
TMP
um only part of its temporary some of it
is kind of useful
so if you look in TMP we have a
directory called deploy
there's a subdirectory to that called
images and a subdirectory to that called
qemu arm
so that contains the compiled image
which I can use for my target
the next three slides are going through
that in slightly more detail I'm
slipping a little bit behind schedule so
I'm going to skip these a little bit
um I think it will become obvious when
we see the result
hopefully of that bit bake
let me just say a little bit about these
image formats so when I say bit big
something image what actually is going
to happen
well it depends on the configuration of
the machine so essentially bit bake is
going to build an image of a format
suitable for your Target Hardware
the kind of formats you're going to have
then are going to be things like maybe
just a pure tar file
so you can then untie that into an
appropriate file system and there's your
root file system
or you can tell it to generate
the root file system in a formatted
image format
so for example ext4 or maybe jff S2
which is for flash memory or ubfs which
is another flash format and various
others
in that case you would just do a DD or
equivalent onto your your target device
um or you can actually use something
called Wick which is the actually I
don't remember what week stands for it
doesn't matter but it's the it's an
image Creator which will create disk
images in other words including a
partition table and you can just DD the
the entire disk image to the root of a
block device
hopefully an SD card and um you can then
plug that into your target device and
the way it goes
so just for reference then these the
types of image that are generated for
any particular machine are set up
in the configuration file for your
machine and you have imagefs types ext3
tar bz2 or whatever
now
normally this is given to you as part of
the board support package for whichever
board you're using you don't normally
have to go and edit this stuff
let me just say a little bit about the
shared State cache
so as bitbake is going through building
stuff it takes a copy of all the build
artifacts and puts them into a directory
called s State cache
and the nice thing about this is that
once you have warmed up the cache or
pre-filled it you can then rebuild the
same thing again uh much more quickly
because you're missing out the compile
stage you just need to copy the
appropriate objects so that's why it was
chugging through really quickly on my
laptop it's not my laptop is
particularly fast it's just that
actually I'm cheating a little bit by
using a shared State cache which has
already been primed with all the stuff I
know we need
and you kind of saw when I did that
paste from the crib sheet I was setting
a couple of variables uh one is called
estate deer another one is DL deer
um so I set them two paths which
um point to pre-loaded Shared State
cache and downloads
so hopefully
yes
um
so coming back here then we can see that
that has all completed
and if I look into the TMP whoops
DMP
um
deploy images
help you in your arm
so these are the images it has generated
um the one we need actually for runtime
is going to be this ext4 image because
we're going to pass that as a parameter
to QE mu
um there should be somewhere here yeah
there's a kernel image so Z image is
there is Linux
and there's some modules and various
other bits and pieces
so I'm going to run that now I'm going
to run
[Music]
so I can use a command called runq emu
which a little a little script a little
wrapper program
and I'm going to say no graphic
because I just want a text console
uh so now you can see it's booting up so
that's the Linux boot messages
um now it's starting user space
and now we've got a login prompt
login as root there's no password
because this is a debug version
um so there's not a lot going on here
there is
udev tasks RPC bind I'm not exactly sure
why we're doing that there's a log
Daemon there's a couple of network
configuration daemons and whatever
but apart from that there's not a lot
going on
oh and I can prove this as arm we look
at proc CPU info
and scroll back a little bit
so yeah it's an arm V7 processor and
it's emulating that quad core arm V7
and it's 32 bits
Okay so
that's got the system up and running
that's told you a little bit about
um machines and distros and images
so now let's talk a little bit more
about these meta layers The Meta layer
is one of the most useful things really
um that yocto gives us
so this is what you see inside your
bblayers.com file
and it's a pretty simple format it's
just BB layers one of these funny
assignment things and then a list of
meta-somethings or others
so this is just a directory which
contains a layer a bunch of recipes
and when I want to add to this
essentially I just need to add an extra
line to this file
um
yeah we can characteristic we can
characterize layers into three basic
types
there's bsps there's distros and there's
everything else
so the first bunch then the bsps bsp
stands for board support package so this
contains the components the recipe is
needed to build
yocto for your particular Hardware
so the bsp at the very least must
contain a configuration file for your
Hardware so for the Raspberry Pi meta
layer there'll be a raspberry pi.conf
for machine equals Raspberry Pi
in addition to that it probably will
contain some additional stuff so
probably there's some code in there's a
recipe in there to build a bootloader
maybe a custom kernel maybe some
graphics drivers or whatever special
about that particular board
distribution layers Define a distro so
at the very least distribution layers
much contain a confidystro and then the
name of the distro.com file
um
so Pocky is a distro
there's also one called angstrom we
looked at AGL earlier on so there's an
AGL distro which is the automotive grade
Linux thing and so on
and then everything else well that is
everything else so if it's not a bsp and
it's not a distro it's and everything
else so this can contain libraries such
as cute
um it can contain
support for languages so Java and Python
and whatever languages there may be
um and also tools like meta
virtualization which contains stuff for
containers and things meta SE Linux
contains well SE Linux
so there is a repository for these
layers and hopefully this is going to
work
if I actually go yes it does work
so this is the open embedded layer index
and
it lists a whole bunch of layers I've
not counted but there's several hundred
of them
and you can see that they're
characterized so these are bsp layers
and these are for various
um
boards and chips you may recognize some
maybe not
but somewhere down here for example
let's scroll on down a bit we should see
metal Raspberry Pi
yeah there it is so that contains the
board support package for Raspberry Pi's
and yeah and so on and so on and as you
can see there is quite a lot from
there's at least 100 of those
then we have the various distros
um
including AGL for automotive grade Linux
and I noticed angstrom is here I think
angstrom is probably not particularly
supported anymore but
it's the way
and then way down here we get software
so this is things like well whatever
like I say there's someone amongst this
stuff that's cute and there's I just saw
metago go past
I thought go along it actually I think
that's probably out of date I think
golang is now integrated into the the
core layers
anyhow you get the point
so we use this when we want to add
software to our project
so let's do this
uh
so I can select either layers or recipes
let's choose a recipe
and I can just do a search for whatever
it is I'm looking for
so I'm going to take a simple example
suppose we want to add the Nano Editor
to our system
so search for Nano
I'd like to think for a little while and
it says yeah okay we have a recipe
called Nano
um it is a small and friendly console
editor
and I can click on this link here
and it gives me a bit more detail
and it should tell me
should tell me which would tell me
should tell me somewhere the layer I
should get it from I guess I get it from
meta Oe
so this is part of a layer called meta
OE so I need to go into I need to get do
a git clone of that repository there
that includes the entire meta OE layer
which I can then which includes the the
Nano recipe
so
demo adding a layer so what I want to do
then I've already kind of done the
download to make life a little bit
easier
but I should be able to
quit out of that
and again I'm going to cheat a little
bit
but I need just need to go into my uh
sorry I need to add the layer first
which I should be able to do using this
command
yeah I think
so I'm using bit layers and layer and
then a pointer to the directory which
contains the mayor I need layer I need
which you may remember is called meta
Dash Oe
and then doing the wrong thing again
uh yep so I can now run this command
here just to show that the Nano recipe
is available
did that
yeah
unfortunately whenever you do something
it rebuilds a dependency cache which
takes a moment or two
um
and then I just need to add the
uh a a thing to the
um
uh to my local.com that will include the
Nano uh recipe
so I was just stumbling there because I
was looking at the time and I was just
trying to remember what time I finished
I think I've got a few minutes left yet
so when you're doing stuff with
um you octo and open embedded
um it's really important to have some
kind of hobby
um such as plain chess or yoga or
meditation anything that you can use to
fill in the gaps while you're waiting
for things to happen
um if all else fails you can always fall
back to uh sword fights on on office
chairs as
popularized in the the famous cartoon
okay right so that finished and you can
just about see here we now have a
matching recipe and it's in that
directory there and it's nano version
6.2
so I want to add that to my
emu build so conf local conf
and again I'm going to use a crib
just to make sure I don't get it wrong
continue doing that
so I've added the text in here image
install colon append equals space Nano
in double quotes
I will briefly explain what that means
later on but for the moment we can be
happy I think that image install is a
variable it's a bit big variable and
it's basically a list of all the recipes
it's going to build
uh the append operator is going to add
to the end of that list
so we're just adding Nano to the list of
recipes that bit Baker is going to build
for me
so I should be able to do
if I do it right
there we go
I'll just do a bit big Cornish base it
shouldn't take so long this time I mean
it took maybe three or four minutes last
time
so I'll probably hang around just to see
you to see it work
and again this is going to work quite
quickly because I've done this
previously about an hour ago in fact
just to make sure that the shared State
cash was up to date
um yeah unfortunately whenever you
change any file anywhere it seems to go
through and regenerate the shared State
cash but hey that's it
okay I'm really going to wait for this
so apologies
okay so now it's burst into action
um
and it very quickly
obtained the Nano packages from the
shared State cache
and now it's doing a task called do root
FS so this is assembling the root file
system from all the various components
that we've specified including Nano in
this case
and when this is finished
I can just
do a run queue emu
boots up
on
and hopefully I can now go Nano
oops
and I guess control Xbox
dude
and
there we go so hey we can create text
files and edit them using Nano
probably not that useful in the grand
scheme of things but it was a good
little demonstration I think
so hopefully then you get this idea
about layers containing recipes and then
we add recipes by
essentially adding a dependency on that
recipe which we did in this case by
using that image install append syntax
so for the final section
yeah we can do this
um
I need to talk a little bit about
recipes so I want you to see what a
recipe is
um at least in in principle and um yeah
we'll try adding a recipe of Our Own
so a recipe contains the instructions on
how to fetch configure compile and
install a software component
so this can be a library can be an
executable it can just be a script or a
configuration file it doesn't have to
have the compile stage if you don't want
to actually compile it
um
at the base a recipe is a list of tasks
and tasks are called things like do
compile or do install or something
generally speaking you don't need to
specify every single task in every
recipe because you and you will inherit
behavior from bitbake which will fill in
most of the default but most of the
tasks with defaults
so you just need to add in overrides for
the things that are special for your
recipe
so here is a simple recipe
and this is going to build a hello world
program for us
um
so we start off with some just human
readable description staff
um these first two lines are not
strictly speaking necessary but they're
handy
then we have some stuff to do with
licenses
so
it's a build error not to specify a
license everything has a license
so in this case we have an MIT license
and not only do you need to see what the
license is you need to give a pointer to
the text of that license and also a
check sum of that text
so you can't cheat the system
you have to have an actual license with
an actual checksum
and it's a build error if none of that
works
then we have Source URI so the source
Uris is a list of places to go get
things
um in a more realistic case the source
of your eyes would be web addresses or
git archives or something but in this
simple case we are using a local file
mime type so this is going to go and
grab a file called hello world.c from
within
uh well okay actually comes from within
a directory called files in the
directory that contains the BB file
then we have do compile and do install
so these are the special things that we
need to do for this recipe
so do compile is going to compile hello
world and output an executable called
hello world
and then do install is going to install
that executable into dollar binder
so dollar bindia is going to work out to
be uh user bin
so we create the user bin directory here
and then we install the executable into
that directory
now when you build a recipe
it will generate packages
and this is a thing that's not
particularly well described in the open
embedded documentation and even
the developers tend to misuse these
terms in my opinion
um so just just be clear a recipe is
something not BB it's a file
but the packages it generates are
multiple
um so this is a case of a library uh Zed
lib sorry lib Zed which is the
compression Library
you get in in this example at least you
get six different packages
you get the runtime which contains the
dot ISO file
you get the debug which contains the so
file with debug symbols
you get the dev which contains the
header file
uh you get the dark which contains
basically the Man pages actually nobody
cares
um you get the source so that's handy
for debugging because you need a source
code if you're using Source level
debugging
and you get static Dev which nobody ever
uses but that includes the
um the a file the archive if you want to
statically link against uh lib Zed which
probably you don't want to do but you
can if you want
so the point is then a single recipe
typically generates multiple packages
and notice these are these are in a
format called RPM the red hat package
manager is just a standard container for
uh
yeah for packages
and then to add a package
um
to our Target
there are multiple ways of doing this
the way I'm doing it here is using this
image install variable
so we have things like image install
append and we can give a list of
packages in this case drop bear which is
an SSH Daemon and like ttpd which is a
little web server
there are other ways of doing it which
I'm not going to differentiate with
right now and notice we're using a
different Syntax for adding here than
here for obscure reasons which I'm
really not going to go into
so
yeah
um
final demo then I'm going to add that
hello world
to my
octo
okay so the first thing I need to do
actually is to create a layer
because recipes live within layers
so I want to create my own layer where I
can put this stuff
and again if I just grip this
I'm going to call my layer meta example
so do that
so bit layers create layer
oh I've missed the ER never mind
and it actually it tells me what to do
next it says I need to add bit layers
add layer meta example
without the e
hoping that works yep so now I have
forgot the level
it uh whoops
example
and that contains a configuration file
you also get for free recipes Dash
something
which contains a does nothing recipe
so I'm just going to copy
and
oops
why isn't that there
yes I thought it was in this directory
should be here
okay this is going somewhat wrong
oh well okay we can do it the hard way
um if I go into meta
example
this
um actually I can cheat I know I've got
a copy hidden away somewhere bear with
me it's a fairly long path name
not uh
Solutions I think
um kind of recipes
do it went
yeah thank you
very good
so there's my hello world I just want to
treat
oh I'm in the wrong director and that's
the problem
oh dear okay demo effect
um
example
yeah okay so now I've got hello world
files there's the hello world C file and
there's the recipe
okay so CD dollar bill dear
going to conf
ident on here
and then do a bit big
okay and that is now going to pick up my
recipe I hope and add a hello world
program to my target
come back to that in a moment or two
pretty much done
um I'd like to add a couple of minutes
for questions although we're running out
of time a little bit
um conclusions well
so the Octo project is industry standard
um pretty much anybody doing embedded
Linux systems is going to be using yocto
at some point or other
um good things about the Octo project is
first of all it produces reproducible
builds so because we're building from
source code each time we know that when
we do the build we know exactly what's
on the build we know the ancestry of
every single component
it gives us a license manifest because
all this licensed stuff we kind of
looked at so you can just uh run a
command and it dumps out all the
licenses you're using
and it can also generate an uh software
bill of materials an s-bomb
which is becoming more and more
important as we want to track the uh the
ancestry and and the the dependencies we
have on a particular project
layers key concept allows us to add
recipes from third parties and also
scales well to large teams we can have
multiple teams each working in their own
layer and then they don't tread onto
each turbo each other's toes too often
finally I haven't mentioned sdks at all
but you can generate an SDK from yocto
which essentially just the cross
compilers and necessary libraries
and you can then give that to the people
in your project who don't really care
about your octo and don't need to know
about yocto but simply want to write
applications in queued or whatever for
your Target product
so a quick looks if my build finished
do around qemu
dot the dark
why is not there
no
I think
and the major thing is going to happen
is our Filipino world and it will say
hello world
but hey I will say that the hello world
is kind of the gateway drug for
programmers if you can write hello world
you can write any program anywhere
so that's that's why we always start by
writing hello world
they were it worked
so thank you all very much
um we have pretty much zero time for
questions I'm sorry about that but we
could maybe squeeze a couple in slides
are available here
uh you can contact me via Twitter and
Twitter Twitter
and or Twitter in if you like
um uh at tunet software and you can link
with me on LinkedIn
so we have time for maybe a couple of
questions without intruding too much
onto the next link so any questions
very quickly
are we all totally overwhelmed yes sir
tricky question
um so the question is if I'm if the
board support package I'm given has a
vendor kernel in it can I replace that
with a Mainline kernel
because
not really
so it it all comes down to the board
support package so the bsp recipe you
have
will amongst other things
um Define the Linux kernel it's going to
use
so if you get a recipe for an a free
scale or sorry an nxp imx8 then that
will use the free scale kernel if you
get a recipe for Raspberry Pi that will
use the Raspberry Pi kernel and so on
and so on
so generally speaking the vendor Colonel
comes as part of the part of the deal
okay
okay question if I use the set if I put
the shared State cash onto an NFS
servers I kind of hinted
in the slides
can that mess things up and that I guess
the simple answer is yes
it can definitely mess things up
um if you do things right you can keep
the Clash clean and and you can
everybody can uh who's using that file
can can benefit from it
um but there are if you look at the mail
list one of the most common uh questions
on the mail list is you know how do I
how do I set up my shared State cache
correctly so it doesn't uh screw up
so I'm just going to say that yes it is
a potential problem if you do it right
it's a huge benefit
um but if not you can waste a lot of
time
regenerating the cash because someone
somewhere has messed it up
sorry I can't go any more detail than
that just now
is that
uh yeah okay so I kind of skipped over
that a little bit when I talked about
the licensing so everything must have a
license
with um closed source code you have
basically two options uh you can use a
license type called proprietary
um and then you just get the text and
check some of the license file so this
assumes you have uh the license files as
a text file that's that's accessible to
you
or you can set the license to be closed
in uppercase which means you don't have
to have a license file
so either way around you can supply
either your own license or you can just
put close which says this is closed
Source um and the license is defined
somewhere else
okay
um okay two more and then we'll finish
so uh yes sir
so do you build in a container or do you
build a native on on Linux
um
probably is worthwhile putting it into a
container so you can so I mean the the
build system is sensitive to the
operating system it's running on top of
so typically
the yocto developers support the three
most recent versions of Ubuntu Susie
percent also something I don't remember
exactly this list but if you are trying
to build an older version which is using
an older operating system which you may
not have available to you then yes a
container would help you avoid some of
those dependencies
okay last question
uh there is a so it's not built so the
s-bomb is not generated every time you
do a build there is a special thing you
do and off the top of my head I can't
remember what it is to cause it to spit
out the the s-bomb so yeah it's it's on
demand
okay so thank you all very much for uh
for listening to me hope that was in
some way useful
and
um I shall be doing a further talk on
embedded Linux in about 50 minutes time
so thank you very much